let's give this a go i did it in four
lines
though i did do a couple of steps
sometimes so hold on to your hats
what are you gonna do first i generally
try when i can
to take a gaussian elimination approach
to it so i work down on these rows over
here
particularly they look easier to work on
look at this one all i have to do
is get rid of like i don't have to
change it very much
so in order to get to there first you've
got to use you've got to use something
from these rows up here
okay now look at that two and that
negative two so many of you might have
tried straight off
adding the first two rows okay that'll
eliminate it from here and i'll just
have a three over there right so let's
give this a go
if i add um this to this i should have
five up there
zero zero is that all right
but because i've got this augmented
matrix over here the whole thing is
augmented
i'm gonna have to add this one up here
all right so i'll get one
one zero is that right so you'll see the
right hand side it will get
progressively messier
as the left hand side becomes
progressively neater
all right that's all i did for this
operation there wasn't anything that i
saw
particularly useful that i could do with
these roads
but then where i went from there was
here look you've got a five and that's
it
so clearly the next step on this top row
should be
divide good that's not so hard which
gives you 0.2
0.2 and that's still zero
but once you've got this you can
immediately use it on the next row
okay so not only am i gonna divide by
five here
i'm gonna work on row two and i can use
row one in its current form
how will i use it i should
subtract two lots of
row one you see that
so this two here that i want to get rid
of i'm gonna use this one to get rid of
it
okay so what's gonna happen all of these
are zeros right so i don't need to worry
about them
this is going to cancel that's still
going to be negative 2.
but now you've got to watch out okay so
i want two lots of these that should be
sorry two lots of these so that's 0.4
okay
i'm going to subtract 0.4 from
everything down here so this will become
negative
point four this will become point six
and this is still zero so far so good
two row operations generally enough for
my brain when there's only three to play
with so i'm gonna leave row three zero
one one zero zero one now you can see
why i only have one line left
right can you see what i'm going to do
two hits
i'm going to um what was i gonna do
oh yeah okay so i'm going to divide this
second row
by negative two because that's going to
make that one is that all right
okay so i'm gonna go first row is fine
divide this row by negative two
to get rid of that sign okay so it
should be zero
zero one that's good okay watch out
what's going to happen to these guys the
signs are gonna flip
right and they're all going to get half
the size so this should become positive
0.2
and this will be negative 0.3
yep following now
i can immediately use this new modified
row 2
to fix up row 3 right because all i need
to do is
subtract it there's a 1 here and that
one is the one i want to get rid of
so i'll go row 3 minus row
2. okay you do have to watch out with
your negatives okay
let's give it a go this is going to
become 0 1 0. so i tell a lie i need one
more step to i've got to swap these to
get the proper identity matrix
okay but then i am taking 0
take away 0.2
zero take away negative point three
so positive point there and then
one take away zero
okay so essentially i'm done now you
just need to swap
rows two and three so now i can write
out
i'll replace the um actually i'll pop it
over here
i'll pop it next to the original red
matrix now i should have
this as my inverse okay let me take
this guy it should look like this
0.2 0.20
negative 0.2 three one
point two negative point three zero
there we go if i multiply those out
i should get i should get the identity
matrix okay
and you're welcome to test it out when i
did
it seemed to work out okay but i'd like
you to work out the dot products
just so you can practice and convince
yourself that yes this is the answer
especially when sometimes
you're like maybe you're off by a
negative or you've got like 0.7 instead
of 0.3 or something like that
really easy to check which is